President Trump faces down China North
Korea and Iran 2020 Democrats swing
further to the left and we checked the
mailbag I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show Wow a lot to get to today
actually a pretty busy news day
shockingly it's not even time for the
Friday news dump yet I'm sure there'll
be more happening later on today we'll
get to everything but first this
Mother's Day for a limited time only
23andme is taking 30 bucks off their
health and ancestry kit until May 13th
celebrate what makes mom special with
personalized genetic insights on her
health traits and more with 23andme x'
health and ancestry kit she can discover
how her genes may influence her health
with more than 125 personalized genetic
reports that feature information on her
traits and health like genetic weight
caffeine consumption sleep movement and
much more well 23andme is personalized
wellness reports she can learn how her
genes play a role in her well-being in
lifestyle choices whether it's how her
weight weight may be impacted by
saturated fat her likelihood of for
being lactose intolerant and more mom is
sure to discover a whole new way of
understanding who she is you could learn
how her genetics could influence her
health this Mother's Day get 30 bucks
off that 23andme health and ancestry kit
at 23andme comm slash Shapiro that's the
number two three and me.com slash up
here I've taken the 23andme genetic test
and a lot of great information about my
own health also about my ancestry which
it turns out is pretty monolithically
Jewish but you can find out all of this
stuff with 23andme that's 23andme comm
slash Shapiro the offer ends May 13th
23andme comm slash apparel go check them
out right now 23andme comm slash Shapiro
okay so we begin today with the media's
attempts to continue to paint the Trump
administration as engaged in some sort
of cover-up last night James Comey
appeared on CNN and appearing on CNN he
was asked basically to rip everyone
inside the Trump administration to talk
about how evil the Trump administration
was to talk about how President Trump
obstructed justice now James Comey has a
dog in this fight okay James Comey was
his firing led off the entire
obstruction of justice
debacle it was James Comey firing which
by the way was perfectly appropriate
he should've been fired as soon as
president Trump took office frankly
Obama should have fired him after he did
that press conference about Hillary
Clinton back in July of 2016 but Jim's
was fired for cause he was bad at his
job he was politically motivated his
politics were all about preserving his
picture of the FBI as an institution but
Trump fired him and then Trump basically
said that he fired him because Comey
wouldn't say publicly the Trump wasn't
under investigation which was true Trump
was not under investigation Comey
wouldn't say it
he explained to Trump why he wouldn't
say it Trump got frustrated Trump fired
him
then Trump went on national TV and said
I guess this Russia stuff is done
because now we can openly say I'm not
under investigation
that's what Trump meant James Comey and
the rest of the media took that to mean
Trump fired Comey in order to stymie the
investigation now as we know the
investigation was not stymied we keep
hearing there's been a cover-up there's
been obstruction we keep hearing that
President Trump is involving himself in
the nitty-gritty details of the Muller
report of the investigation in an
attempt to prevent public knowledge of
the nefarious activities in which he
participated I've seen not a lot
evidence of that the fact is we are all
privy to the Muller report the fact is
Robert Muller were James Comey was fired
in the middle of 2017 it is now the
middle of 2019 it is two years later
that is when we got the Muller report so
for two full years Robert Muller had
access to pretty much everyone inside
the Trump administration to millions of
documents to grand jury testimony so the
idea that James commis firing
represented some sort of obstruction of
justice is simply absurd but Comey is
very invested in that narrative because
otherwise got fired for being crappy at
his job and that James Comey can't
accept so he's been going around for the
last couple of years taking taking
aspirational pictures of himself in
great places of nature looking up at the
forest looking down at the ocean and
then pondering life well now he's back
on CNN he's being brought back forth by
the media to explain exactly why it is
that President Trump is a very very bad
cruel bad orange man so here is Comey
explaining the Trump obstructed justice
according to James Comey I'll explain
how absurd this is in just a second
there now what it's I think it's up to
800 former federal prosecutors who've
worked in both Republican and Democratic
administrations who have signed a
statement saying the Moeller's findings
would have produced obstruction charges
against President Trump if he weren't
president do you agree yeah I agree
no doubt no doubt again there's ten
different episodes I actually think the
ones that would be most likely charged
are not necessarily the
ones that involved me but particularly
this Magan episode and another episode
where he was trying to get the Attorney
General to limit the investigation only
to future elections are examples that
any reasonable prosecutor would charge
okay so that is that is really an
amazing statement by James Comey now the
reason it's an amazing statement is
because the reason that Trump could not
be charged with obstruction of justice
is because of a strep obstruction of
justice is in fact a crime that requires
intent it's a crime that requires you to
intend to obstruct justice you want to
stop the investigation because you think
it's going to uncover something in the
absence of an underlying crime it's very
difficult to obstruct justice because
what exactly would your intent be just
because you're annoyed like that doesn't
really meet the intent portion which is
why when William bar explained why he
had not decided to indict Trump on
obstruction of justice he pointed to two
factors one Trump's mental state and two
the fact that there was no underlying
collusion for Trump to cover up and that
was William bars take and that is a
correct take James Comey is saying that
take is entirely wrong Trump had the
requisite intent okay question
it was James Comey I remember who said
about Hillary Clinton that Hillary
Clinton was not guilty of violating
rules about classified material because
she did not have the requisite intent
you know where intent is not an element
of the crime when it comes to the
mishandling of classified material you
do not have to intend to expose
classified material to prying eyes you
do not have to intend to do anything
wrong it is a strict liability crime if
you take classified materials and you
put them in public view you are guilty
of the crime James Comey personally
wrote intent into a law that had no
intent and now he's writing intent out
of the law to castigate President Trump
which does demonstrate a fair bit of
political bias on the part of the guy
who proclaims that he is a wonderful law
enforcement officer without any bias
James Comey went on to explain that the
DOJ should actually charge President
Trump when he is no longer president you
think he should be charged when he's out
of office
I think they saw what Muller has shown
well I think the Justice Department I'll
have to take a serious look at that
whether it's a wise thing to do to a
former president I don't know that's a
harder question a much bigger question
than the facts of the case but do you
think the evidence is there to to
prosecute sure looks like it's there
with
respect to at least a couple of those
episodes of obstruction okay so you know
the idea that he is going to now push
forward that Trump should be prosecuted
when he's no longer president well again
you know who could have made that call
you know who could have said that Robert
Muller could have said that
hey Robert Muller had every capacity to
say listen according to the DOJ rules
according to the Office of Legal Counsel
it is unlikely that you can prosecute
the presidents on these charges however
I would recommend an obstruction charge
against the president were it not for
these OLC rules meaning that he should
be prosecuted when he's no longer
president robert muller could have said
that in every ability to say that he did
not say that
why not because he didn't want to I mean
it's pretty clear that his team wanted
to get Trump it's pretty team pretty
obvious his team thought that Trump did
immoral bad stuff that's the entire
volume 2 of the report but the fact that
that Muller didn't do it is somewhat
telling here's what's really going on
James Comey is mad because he got fired
and he effectively admits as much to
Anderson Cooper you were at an FBI
Bureau I think in Los Angeles and you
actually saw it on CNN that you had been
fired I'm wondering two years later with
all that's happened how do you look back
on that moment I was numb because I
didn't expect to be fired I was actually
in a room about this size talking to
custodial staff employees about the
importance of the FBI's mission I looked
over their heads and saw first I said
call me resigns which I thought was
probably a prank and then it said call
me fired and I know this may sound
strange but I didn't expect to be fired
never entered my mind I knew by that
point the president didn't like me but I
thought that's okay because that'll keep
a separation so it still feels a little
bit numbing frankly it's numbing it's
hurt there's a lot of emotion in James
Comey for a guy who pretends that he is
just motivated that he is just motivated
specifically by all of this that he's
motivated specifically by desire to
enforce the law
now hilariously Comey was asked about
the FBI under his auspices two of his
top agents where Peter struck and Lisa
Paige they're having an affair with one
another struck was personally heading up
about the Hillary investigation as well
as the Trump investigation and Comey
Yvette's uh yeah they may have made us
look bad you know what the whole texting
each other
and talking about how much they hated
Trump
and then Peter struck manipulating the
investigation the timing of the
investigation that's not according to me
it's not according to Trump that's
according to the Inspector General of
the DOJ Michael Horowitz who found that
ironically that struck had actually put
the Hillary investigation on the
backburner in favor of the Trump
investigation and the irony comes in in
that because he put the Hillary
investigation on the backburner the
investigation only started to look at
Huma Abedin computer like a week before
the election and if he had not done that
then they probably uncovered that a
month earlier and they take care of it a
month earlier and Hillary has a better
shot at winning the election here as
Comey admitting yeah you know I was
running the FBI but my top agents they
made us look real bad do you knowledge
that that this whole episode was struck
and and page that it damaged the
reputation of the FBI and perhaps
tarnished the investigation definitely
yeah
very painful it was important that it be
investigated and important that there be
discipline that follows it but yeah made
us all look bad Peter struck is a very
talented agent it's a personal tragedy
for him but as much as I care about
individuals I care about the institution
more it hurt the institution okay so you
know what else hurt the institution you
overseeing all of that you overseeing
all of that hurt the institution so the
fact that James Comey is still being
trotted out as some sort of authority on
this stuff does demonstrate that the
media are pretty biased on this sort of
thing I mean they could be asking James
Comey all the same questions that I'm
asking what is your evidence that Donald
Trump had requisite intent we know that
he fired you not because he wanted to
obstruct the investigation the
investigation was not obstructed so what
exactly are you talking about don't you
have a personal stake in making this
case but they're gonna keep trying it's
amazing how all you have to do to become
a hero of the resistance is stop Hillary
Clinton from becoming president and then
yell at President Trump amazing if it
were not for James Comey much better
shot Hillary Clinton is sitting in the
White House right now if it were not for
James Comey then it's quite possible
that the entire Trump Russia collusion
investigation would have gone down the
drain much earlier so the whole thing is
pretty amazing okay in just a second
we're gonna get to the actual big story
of the day which is not any of the fake
obstruction stuff it's not any of the
ridiculous Senate investigations or
House investigations the big story of
the day is that we made
in a full-on trade war with China which
is dangerous stuff I'll get to that in a
second first getting fit and staying
healthy it always sounds easier said
than done right open fit is bringing you
something new that makes it even easier
to never miss a sweat session lose the
commutes of the gym let the workouts
come to you my wife particularly loves
open fit I work out with her at night
using open fit because she's really busy
during the day you know taking care of
patients and everything she comes home
it's time to work out open fit is what
we do open fit takes all of the
complexity out of losing weight and
getting fit it's a brand new super
simple streaming service that allows you
to work out from the comfort of your
living room in as little as 10 minutes a
day everyone's bodies are different open
if it gets that which is why it is
personalized your needs with custom
tailored original content open fit
classes are led by some of the most
effective and engaging trainers in the
world
forget all the complexity and stress
around getting fit just press play and
work out on your schedule view on your
computer web enabled TV tablet
smartphone and Roku lose up to 15 pounds
in just the first 30 days flat in the
ABS shape the body look and feel great
as I say I use open fit myself my wife
uses it as well been using it virtually
every night it's fantastic open fit
changes the way I workout with my coach
Shapiro you can join me on a fitness
journey personalized just for you again
use my coach Shapiro start using open
fit for your journey to a healthier life
right now during the open fit 30-day
challenge my listeners get a special
extended 30-day free trial membership to
open fit you can lose up to 15 pounds in
30 days text Shapiro to 30 30 30 again
just texture pro2 30 30 30 get full
access to open fit all the workouts and
nutrition information totally free text
Shapiro to 30 30 30 okay well the actual
big story of the day is the possibility
of a trade war with China China said on
Friday it's going to retaliate because
the United States did move to increase
tariffs on hundreds of billions of
dollars worth of Chinese products on
Friday effectively breaking a month-long
truce
seriously complicating ongoing talks
according to the Global Times which is a
Chinese publication the Chinese side
deeply regrets the u.s. actions and
we'll have to take countermeasures the
Chinese Ministry of Commerce said in a
statement after the United States
started to raise tariffs on Chinese
goods following through an earlier
threats by US officials the u.s. raised
a ten percent tariff on 200 billion
dollars worth of Chinese products
including electronics clothes and toys
to 25 percent starting at 12:01 p.m.
Friday Beijing time the higher tariffs
will apply to u.s. bound products that
left China after 12:01 a.m.
on Friday u.s. time according to Reuters
citing the US Customs and Border
Protection such a grace period was not
offered in the previous three rounds of
tariffs apparently the the government of
China's statement did not specify what
countermeasures China would take and
when it would implement those
countermeasures but analysts said there
were several measures China could take
that would inflict pain on the United
States economy and that the measures
would be announced shortly he Wayne wen
is a former senior Chinese trade
official told the Global Times I think
China will respond very soon
China will also have to make good on its
own words otherwise it will be at a huge
disadvantage to the US team at the
negotiations now one of the things that
has been happening is that President
Trump has been sending some mixed
signals on all of this now what you want
when it comes to foreign policy
particularly is very consistent policy
as I've been saying for years president
Trump's view of tariffs is wrong his
view of tariffs is that tariffs make
America richer that if all we did was
raise trade barriers on imports of
products from other countries we would
actually be bringing manufacturing home
and the American people would be more
prosperous and richer manufacturing
would return to America's Shores
historically this is not what tariffs
has done historically what tariffs have
done is is decimate your capacity to
compete on a global level lead to
outsourcing by companies job loss and
stagnation in the country in which the
tariffs are applied that's because costs
go up right we are all much producers we
are all consumers
well tariffs do is they benefit a
specific segment of the market at the
expense of all the other consumers so
let's say you have a tariff on Chinese
steel that benefits the American steel
producers because now they no longer
have to compete with the Chinese steel
producers but American steel consumers
including the car companies those people
are going to be paying higher prices
that is reflected on to consumers and so
it's less money in your pocket taras
foster political dysfunction by creating
conflicts between various interest
groups in the United States as well as
with foreign countries now this does not
mean that tariffs can't be a useful tool
of policy and this is where it's
important to understand what President
Trump is doing and important for him to
be consistent in just a second I'm going
to explain so the consistent policy here
should be and would be look we don't
want any tariffs no tariffs at all the
only reason that we have tariffs right
now is because China is cheating on
trade and by cheating on trade we don't
mean that they're subsidizing particular
core into
that's not cheating on trade they get to
do that it's their policy it's dumb
government top-down policy that
subsidizes certain industries at the
expense of other industries typically
does not end well even for those
industries because once those companies
are taken off the subsidies they fail to
be competitive and the free market is
great at creating durable companies that
are capable of competing in a global
market without subsidies once you start
subsidizing things people become
dependent on the subsidies this is what
happened to the American car companies
in the 1950s and 60s
America's car companies used to run the
world then we started subsidizing them
we had lots of tariffs against foreign
imports and America became much less
competitive feasibly the rest of the
world so it is missed so if other
countries choose to subsidize those
industries that's not really an excuse
for us to tariff them what is an excuse
for us to tariff them is them cheating
on intellectual property for him for
example the government participating in
stealing American intellectual property
now we've taken these cases to the World
Trade Organization China has not been a
good actor in the World Trade
Organization with regard to paying up
when they've been found guilty those
procedures take a lot of time so if you
really want to inflict pain on China to
get them to stop stealing intellectual
trade property intellectual property
then that is at least understandable the
problem for President Trump is that he
sends mixed signals one signal is we
don't want any tariffs but if we have to
punish you we will and the other signal
that's sort of Larry Kudlow signal the
other signal is tariffs are great so
president from today for example is
tweeting out about how tariffs are a
wonderful thing so President Trump is is
tweeting out right now that if you
produce in America there will be no
tariffs right he says he says great
consumer price index just out really
good very low inflation we have a great
chance to really rock good numbers all
around your favorite president your
all-time favorite president so so Trumpy
your all-time favorite president got
tired of waiting for trying to help out
and start buying from our farmers the
greatest anywhere in the world build
your products in the United States and
there are no tariffs he says if we
bought fifteen billion dollars of
Agriculture from our farmers far more
than China buys now we'd have more than
eighty five billion dollars left over
for new infrastructure health care or
anything else China would greatly slow
down and we would automatically speed up
tariffs will make our country
stronger not weaker just sit back and
watch in the meantime China should not
renegotiate deals with the United States
at the last minute this is not the Obama
administration or the administration of
sleepy Joe who let trying to get away
with quote-unquote May Day so again this
is the mixed signal we want free trade
but we don't want free trade tariffs are
actually good tariffs are actually
tariffs for actually wonderful and this
is the this is the push that that Trump
himself is making and that is sending
mixed signals to the market because the
market is saying okay well if he is
happy with the tariffs if he likes the
tariffs if all of this was an excuse to
get to the tariffs then maybe he just
wants to leave those in place and if he
just wants to leave those in place that
could cost all of us a lot of money he
cut it because tariffs actually has just
a policy not as tool of leverage but as
a policy are pretty bad this is what the
UK son reports today Donald Trump wiped
nearly 1.5 trillion dollars off global
markets with a single Twitter blast
vowing to double tariffs on Chinese
goods after they broke a crucial trade
deal that was two days ago u.s.
president renewed hostilities between
the two economic shines by threatening
to once more ramp up the cost of Beijing
trading in the United States he pledged
to hike tariffs on 200 billion dollars
of Chinese goods from Friday rocking
equity markets across the world and
that's because equity markets have
typically thought that Trump was a lot
of bluster but once these things kick in
the feeling is that Trump wants to leave
them in place not because they're good
policy but specifically because he
actually likes tariffs and now he is
causing all sorts of confusion again on
Twitter according to Bloomberg President
Trump the morning after levying fresh
tariffs on China caused confusion among
traders by tweeting that there is no
need to rush on China trade meaning okay
maybe we'll just leave these tariffs in
place for a while and the markets went
oh boy that's not good now one of the
things that people have been ignoring
about the the fact that the markets have
been quite hot to this point is that
there has been a bit of anticipation of
this in the markets the markets were
anticipating at the end of last year the
tariffs were going to kick in and so
they accelerated a lot of their buying
from foreign manufacturers and that led
to an increase in the amount of spending
the amount of dollars flowing through
the United States economy it caused a
lot of imports to be bought for example
that's why the trade deficit is actually
getting worse under President Trump an
earlier tweet was deleted and then
reposted with minor changes he tweeted
out this morning talks with China
continuin of
congenial manner there's absolutely no
need to rush as tariffs are now being
paid to the United States by China of
25% on two hundred fifty billion dollars
worth of goods and products these
massive payments go directly to the
Treasury of the United States well
that's not really how tariffs work that
really is not how tariffs work
I mean tariffs only work if we buy a
product it's a tax on a product but a
consumers feel they feel the brunt of
that it's not as though China just pays
the tax and then sends its product into
our market and its previous price that's
not how any of this works tariffs II
said again would make the United States
much stronger not weaker just sit back
and watch China of course has said that
it wants to retaliate so there's a
battle inside the Trump administration
right now between the Larry Kudlow and
between President Trump and Peter
Navarro who's one of his trade advisers
on China who really is not particularly
good at his job all of this is creating
disquiet in the market again I think
that if President Trump were using trade
barriers as leverage to push China to
start adhering to intellectual property
law that would at least be excusable I
think there are other measures that can
be used but that at least is an excuse
for him to be proclaiming that tariffs
are inherently good is just not true the
smoot-hawley Tariff at the beginning of
the Great Depression helped exacerbate
the Great Depression by leading other
countries to raise their tariffs as well
and all of that led to less of an export
market for American goods and higher
prices for American workers that's what
tariffs effectively do it doesn't create
more jobs it doesn't create more
prosperity it creates more conflicts it
creates higher prices it creates less of
an export market for competitive
American goods in a second we'll get to
where things are going on China plus
conflict brewing with North Korea as
well first hye-rin used to be hard
multiple job sites stacks of resumes a
confusing review process but today
hiring can be easy you only have to go
to one place to get it done in zip
recruit calm slash daily wire zip
recruiter sends your job to over 100 of
the web's leading job boards but they
don't stop there with their powerful
matching technology zip recruiter scans
thousands of resumes to find people with
the right experience and then invites
them to apply to your job as
applications come in zip recruiter
analyzes each one and spotlights the top
candidates so you never miss a great
match
zip recruiter is so effective that four
out of five employers who post on zip
recruiter
get a quality candidate through the site
within the very first day right now my
listeners can try zip recruiter for free
at this exclusive web address zip
recruiter comm slash daily wire that's
zip recruiter comm slash a Dai ly WI re
zip recruiter comm slash daily why're we
a zipper creditors if recruiter right
here at the daily wear offices every
time we need to make a new hire we're
using zip recruiter to make our jobs
easier and simpler and more efficient
you can do that too
zip recruiter is the smartest way to
hire go try them out right now for free
at SIP recruiter com
slash a daily wire that zip recruiter
com slash daily wire alright so the New
York Times reports that now President Xi
is facing a dilemma should he fold or
should he double down and this is where
the good side of of president Trump's
push could be right if you're using
tariffs as a leverage point and not as
an actual policy there's a case for that
here's what the New York Times says as
Chinese and American officials try to
reach a trade deal President Xi Jinping
faces a painful possibly damaging choice
to try to protect his aura of
indomitable 'ti or retreat after
President Trump accused China of
reneging on the terms of a draft
agreement and threatened to raise
tariffs the stakes rose sharply for the
Chinese leader this week after mr. Trump
and his chief Trade Representative
Robert light Heiser publicly accused
China of backing down on commitments the
sticking point appeared to be a late
decision by mr. ji to reject American
demands that China changed laws
constraining American businesses when
Trump left onto Twitter to complain it
was a public rebuke that put G in a
tight spot she is China's most powerful
leader in decades he guards his images
of visionary statesmen guiding his
country to greatness China's
relationship of the United States is its
most important relationship if ties
between the countries Hartman's manage
that could damage China's economy and
tarnish his image trade talks that just
last week seem close to fruition have
abruptly become a flashpoint in the
rocky relationship she now faces
questions at home over whether he
miscalculated Trump's resolve domestic
rumblings could grow if the United
States forces she to make concessions or
if the talks break down according to
paul henley a former china director on
the national security council who now
runs the carnegie shin watch center for
global policy in beijing quote zi is she
is walking a tightrope he is going to be
the one that has to make the most
concessions and that makes this all the
more difficult for him on Thursday
shortly before the trade talks were set
to resume of course North Korea shot
offshore trade
missiles the United States have been
pushing China to get involved even if
the timing of them launches is a
coincidence perhaps that puts pressure
on the United States to point out that
China needs to be a partner Leo he is
China's chief negotiator he said quote I
come bearing sincerity and hope in the
current special circumstances so the
reason Frank exchange of views with the
US side China believes that increasing
tariffs won't solve problems won't
benefit China or the United States nor
will it benefit the global economy China
had been willing to protect intellectual
property and open its markets to
American business but the Trump
administration wanted the agreement to
specify that some of those changes
actually be made in Chinese law
apparently China didn't want to do that
they wanted to make an informal policy
and Trump was saying no you need to
change your law so that formerly you
cannot renege on this agreement Hwang
Jung is a director of the center for
international political economy at
Peking University he said that would
bring back painful memories of the days
of national humiliation in our history
Trump of course doesn't care too much
about that Trump is trying to push for a
public concession I guess the idea here
is that Trump put if he push for a
private concession maybe they would do
it who the hell knows whether that is
true according to Professor - everyone
must have everyone may have greater
doubts and uncertainty about the future
of the Chinese economy Chinese US
relations or the global economy this
uncertainty will certainly affect
production investment and consumption
Chinese officials are still struggling
to understand the president according to
the New York Times Senator Chris Coons a
Democrat from Delaware said quote there
are a lot of voices in Washington that
are either sharply or harshly critical
of China's action and trade in their
military expansionism
in their actions in the South China Sea
fill in the blank so as I say Trump
being strong with China is fine
Trump embracing tariffs is not so fine
the question is which one of these
things is correct what's actually
happening here now maybe maybe this
works out to the tune of China takes
trump's warm embrace of tariffs as more
of a credible threat than they would
otherwise that that Trump's team and
Trump himself think that if he just says
tariffs are wonderful then China will
back down because they don't want the
tariffs and the tariffs hurt China worse
than they hurt us with that said as a as
a general point of policy I don't think
that that is correct obviously and
so I don't actually think you need to
say that I think that you can simply say
to them listen we got reluctantly
imposing these tariffs because you won't
do X but you know maybe this is
President and Trump selling past the
sale as Scott Adams likes to say that is
a possibility as well will obviously be
watching this closely it's a high-risk
move for president Trump politically
speaking the reason that it is a
high-risk move for President Trump is
because if the tariffs continue it will
undoubtedly damage the United States
economy there's already been talk about
how much more robust the recovery would
be how much were more robust the United
States economy would be right now if we
were not engaged in sporadic trade wars
with various with various folks it does
raise the question overall by the way as
to whether for example the United States
ever should have worked on opening China
in the first place the case for opening
China is that it would make China more
liberal more democratic that of course
has not happened of course it's more
prosperous for both US and China to have
an open trade relationship that is true
regardless of who exactly is in charge
with that said would it have been better
in the 1970s if we didn't open China
when they were in a serious trajectory
toward collapse I don't know I don't
know I mean certainly possible that that
is the case US officials say that they
have more than promises to stop China
from stealing intellectual property
rights this time Robert light Heiser's
the head of the US trade association has
pushed an enforcement system that gives
the u.s. the right to impose tariffs if
it decides that China is not living up
to the deal
China barred from responding in kind so
if we is so China wouldn't be able to to
respond against us Clete Williams a
former senior White House trade official
who is a whozit
akin gump a major law firm he said we've
had these conversations with China for
years if you don't have specific
commitments backed up with enforcement
you don't have anything so again if this
is President Trump being tough with
leverage for it if this isn't president
from embracing tariffs the way he on a
gut level seems to do not really in
favor of it meanwhile chaos still
breaking out on the North Korean
Peninsula on the Korean Peninsula over
the over the course of the last two days
the United States seized a North Korean
freighter that was caught shipping coal
in violation of the United States of UN
sanctions rather the Justice Department
revealed on Thursday the 17,000 ton
cargo ship called the wise honest was
stopped in Indonesia last year after it
was found to be carrying coal the ship's
captain
charged with violating Indonesian law
last July the United States filed an
action to seize the ship and finally
they went ahead and did that North Korea
of course has also fired a couple of
rockets this week in a major move toward
reigniting a lot of the conflicts
between North Korea and the United
States presumably that is because the
Trump administration has been moving
away from concessions to the North
Koreans as they should so there are a
couple ways to read this overall overall
the way to read this could be the
president Trump is getting very tough on
foreign policy and that's great
the other way to read this is that this
is a bit chaotic that we don't actually
know what his foreign policy is and that
foreign actors are taking advantage of
that or acting from confusion you know I
hope that it is the first I think that
it feels like more of the first but it
certainly could be the second okay in
just a second we are going to get to the
latest on the Democrats declaring that
the that the Russia probe is not over
we're also gonna get to the 2020 race
and we got to do mailbag today so we got
a lot coming up first when the founders
crafted the Constitution the first thing
they did was to make sacred the rights
of the individual to share their ideas
without limitation by their government
the second right they enumerated was the
right of the population to protect that
speech and their own persons with force
you know how strongly I believed in
these principles I'm a gun owner owning
a rifle is an awesome responsibility
building rifles is no different Bravo
Company manufacturing was started in a
garage by a Marine veteran more than two
decades ago to build a
professional-grade product that meets
combat standards BCM believes the same
level of protection should be provided
to every American regardless of whether
they are a private citizen or a
professional BCM is not a supporting
arms company they design engineer and
manufacture life-saving equipment they
assume that every rifle leaving their
shop will be used in a life-or-death
situation by a responsible citizen law
enforcement officer or soldier oversees
every components of a BCM rifle is hand
assembled and tested by Americans to a
life-saving standard BCM feels a moral
responsibility as Americans to provide
tools that aren't just gonna fail the
user when it's not just a paper target
but somebody god forbid coming to do
them harm I know personally about this
sort of stuff BCM works with leading
instructors of marksmanship from top
levels from America's Special Ops forces
from Marine Corps force reconnaissance
to US Army Special Operations Forces who
can teach the skills necessary to defend
yourself your family or others to learn
more about Bravo Company
factoring head on over to Bravo Company
MFG comm you can discover more about
their products special offers upcoming
news that's Bravo Company MFG comm you
need more convincing find out even more
about BC I'm at youtube.com slash Bravo
Company USA
that's youtube.com slash Bravo Company
USA okay in just a second we are going
to get to the Democrats Russia probe
push we are also going to get to the
Democrats in the 2020 presidential race
growing more and more radical Bernie
Sanders now openly campaigning with AOC
so things are getting wild first you're
gonna have to go over to daily wire calm
and subscribe when you do you get all
sorts of goodies $9.99 a month means you
get this show it means you get two
additional hours of the show every day
you get to hang out with me behind the
scenes it means that you get the Sunday
special on Saturdays it means you get
all sorts of good stuff art this week
Sunday special features William Lane
Craig the famous philosopher and
theologian we talked about everything
from the reasons for belief in God to
the veracity of the New Testament it's
really good stuff here's a little bit of
what it sounded like in the absence of
some defeater it seems to me that we're
perfectly within our rights in believing
that there is an objective realm of
moral values and duties just as we're
within our rights and believing that
there is a world of physical objects
around us alrighty so it was it's really
good stuff you're gonna want to go check
it out it's really a lot of fun so you
get that on Saturday when you become a
subscriber for $99 a year you also get
this the very greatest and beverage
vessels the leftists here is hot or cold
tumbler go check it out right now it's
pretty fantastic also it's time for a
tumblr promo it's that glorious time of
the week when I give a shout out to a
daily where a subscriber this is why I
should subscribe today Marines would
their ski on Instagram and your dog
knuckles all right in this photo
knuckles is smiling a wide wide dog grin
happy dog he really is smiling it's kind
of weird he's received a signed copy of
my book the right side of history and
his doggy ball has been replaced with
the leftist years tumblr so no wonder he
is happy Maureen writes knuckles was so
happy to get his signed book today he is
studying up so he can destroy his left
his dog friends he has this tumblr all
ready to collect their dog ETS facts
don't care about dogs feelings I don't
know how you would tell the politics of
a dog I think all dogs go to heaven
which means all dogs are conservative
anyway thanks to
Marina and Knuckles for your support
alright so go check us out also at
YouTube or iTunes and we are the one of
the biggest podcast in America we were
ranked second of all podcasts on planet
Earth last month go check us out right
now we always appreciate it leave us a
review we appreciate that too with
largest fastest core and conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
all righty so let's let's talk a little
bit about the Democrats and and the
Russia probe so they continue to claim
that obstruction is occurring obviously
the media are relying on James Comey but
the Democrats just keep saying that
there's obstruction there's obstruction
there is obstruction they keep pushing
this I don't think there's a lot there
for them to grab so Jerry Nadler keeps
saying this is obstruction without any
proof of instruction okay tell us about
it representative Naylor the Attorney
General has told us repeatedly and all
the Republicans that Senator McConnell
and others have told us that the finding
of the malla report was no collusion no
obstruction if that's true why are they
trying to hide it it's obviously not
true private citizens or employees of
the Justice Department must testify for
a congressional or a court subpoena it's
not optional unless they have a legal
reason not to and the so called
executive privilege is nonsense all
righty so this of course is untrue you
know the the the the idea that any
obstruction is taking place he has no
actual evidence of this Muller is going
to testify every aspect of this where
they say president Trump is obstructed
the only area where he can credibly
claim the president Trump did not give
all the information to Muller is the
area where he didn't sit down with
Muller which no lawyer in their right
mind would allow Trump to do this is all
manufactured Nancy Pelosi says she
supports Jerry Nadler however and she
thinks that William bar should
presumably be held in contempt if she
had the courage of her convictions she'd
call for impeachment but she's not doing
that we're talking about a cumulative
effect of obstruction that the
administration is engaged in and the
president declaring that he is not going
to honor any subpoenas from the Congress
so I support the path that our champaner
our chairman are on and I do believe
that it will establish the case for
where we go from here already so you
know again the fact that she is
continuing to push this demonstrates how
dishonest all this is I'm with President
Trump when he says that this has now
become a hoax and a witch-hunt again I
was very skeptical of that sort of
language but now at this point with the
demo
having the mobile report in front of
them and continuing to maintain this
stuff I'm with President Trump now when
when he says that this is a hoax and a
witch-hunt meanwhile the 2020 race
heating up Joe Biden is moving over to
the left in an attempt to cut off Bernie
Sanders Elizabeth Warren and all the
rest of the sort of leftist pack of
hounds who are chomping at his heels so
president so so Vice President Joe Biden
look at how he has switched on illegal
immigration so it used to be that he
thought illegal immigrants should be
deported now he thinks illegal
immigrants should get free health care
effectively speaking here is Joe Biden
now versus then on illegal immigration
to get a paper tube car you force them
everyone to have a criminal background
check you require that they have to have
prove they have a job you have to
require you prove that they have our
paying Social Security and pay their
taxes and then if they do that and
they're prepared to pay a fine over the
next six years they can earn their way
to citizenship they learn to speak
English and learn to deal like everyone
else did in order to gain citizenship
but if they don't then you send them
back you think this undocumented
immigrants who were in this country
and are law-abiding entitled to federal
benefits Medicare Medicaid for example
look I think that anyone who is in a
situation where they're in need of
health care regardless of whether the
documented or undocumented we have an
obligation to see that their character
that's why I think we need more clinics
around the country Oh funny so it seems
like he has changed his tune in just a
little bit what happened to they need to
speak English they need to pay their
taxes they need to pay back taxes and
all of this pretty amazing he is moving
to the left because the entire
Democratic Party is moving to the left
how far to the left
Bernie Sanders is main stream guy AOC is
a main stream gal yesterday they sat
next to each other
the amount of brain power in that room
man that could toast a piece of bread
lightly if it were channeled in
electricity here's Bernie Sanders and
AOC proposing that we make banks out of
the post office many poor people don't
have access to banking services and say
yes the big banks are not worried about
somebody who you know makes 10 bucks an
hour they can't make enough money after
that so we have got to move toward
universal banking through the postal
system you got post offices in almost
every community in America they should
be available to provide basic banking
services so that people do not have to
go into payday lenders okay so it's a
it's pretty amazing even people on the
Left understand that what Bernie Sanders
and aoshi are proposing here making
banks out of the post offices is very
very dumb Kevin Drum has a piece from
years ago about all of this Kevin Drum
is a columnist for Mother Jones which is
a far left magazine and he says what
exactly is the core competency that
would allow the Postal Service to excel
at banking so they say what would make
it good is that there are lots of post
offices you know what else there are
lots of banking outlets lots of banks
like a hundred thousand across the
United States what else would make these
great for banks trust and familiarity
with the postal brand again and not a
lot of people actually trust the post
office and also when when Sanders and
AOC are talking about what exactly
should happen with these small accounts
small accounts do exist at banks and
also there are such things as as payday
lenders and the biggest problem with
providing very small loans from banks is
that the default rate is extraord
so what a OC and Bernie Sanders really
are talking about is the federal
government subsidizing people with
another entitlement program they'll give
loans to people who they know will not
be able to repay those loans in small
amounts via the post office that's the
agenda here but this is the this is the
Democratic Party that Joe Biden is
trying to fend off and that is why Joe
Biden is moving ever more to the left I
mean Bernie Sanders is openly claiming
that we should cap credit card rates so
he wants to take control of the entire
credit industry of the United States can
see how this goes wrong if interest
rates otherwise are set by the market
why have you decided that that a 15
percent cap is where to go half of the
American people today have no wealth at
all they're living paycheck to paycheck
you got a medical emergency your car
breaks down these are desperate people
and then they go to Wall Street and they
are charged outrageous interest rates
Wall Street profits are soaring people
get further and further in debt while
wages remain stagnant this really is
disgusting
and it is got we have to stand up to the
greed of Wall Street and change it if
you voluntarily sign a credit card
statement if you if you if you sign a
contract with a credit card company then
you take out a bunch of credit then you
can't pay it that would be on you that
is a you problem
but Bernie Sanders wants to make every
you problem a wee problem and all of us
problem the problem is when you
collectivise individual problems the
collective tends to fail at the same
rate is the individual okay you know
what let's do some mailbag here because
it's a Friday let's chill out a little
bit Kelly says if William bar the AG
cannot release unredacted information is
it against the law how can Congress
legally compel a US citizen to break the
law does bar have recourse for this
illegal activity against him yes if they
hold him in civil contempt for this it
will end up in the Supreme Court he will
sue them on the basis that this is not
appropriate and that they are compelling
him to violate American law I think he'd
be likely to win in that case Sarah says
hey Ben I'm an English teacher in public
high school this year for the first time
in my career I had a parents strongly
object to the novel To Kill a
Mockingbird she claimed it was
inappropriate and outdated and it made
her daughter uncomfortable and of course
I was racist for choosing to teach it to
my shame I gave in and decided not to
teach the book this year I noticed on
Twitter you said you consider it one of
the top American novels some teachers
have ax bands in the book because they
argue at others african-american
students and should be replaced with a
book written by a person of color I was
wondering what is your argument for the
value of teaching to kill a mockingbird
today's students to kill a mockingbirds
is one of the great American novels it
is not only beautifully written it is a
story about the inculcation of
civilization and morality in children
and the need to defend people who
specifically are being treated as other
for unjust reasons to kill a mockingbird
is one of the great moral stories it's
almost part of the American mythology
this great moral story of Atticus Finch
a southern lawyer who is standing up for
a wrongly accused black man in the in
the Jim Crow South and the consequences
of doing that the consequences for how
you could read that as a racist book is
absolutely beyond me I do not understand
how that is possible but it does show
how the nature of our view of race in
America and really are not even race in
America of how America should view race
has changed to kill a mockingbird is an
aspirational book it's about how we
should treat each other with regard to
race we should treat each other as
individual human beings with innate
human decency and we should aspire to be
Atticus Finch a few years back Harper
Lee's estates released an early draft of
To Kill a Mockingbird in which Atticus
Finch is basically an old racist and
it's about Harper Lee writing about her
father and the the entire book cast
Atticus Finch as an old-style brutal Jim
Crow racist and the critics we're
talking about many of the Curtis were
talking about this book is more of a
real appreciation of what America is and
was than to kill a mockingbird well it
is true there were a lot of old-style
Jim Crow racists in the south during Jim
Crow it is also true that if you want to
teach people about what America can be
you teach them about to kill a
mockingbird if you want to teach people
about what America was then you actually
just show them tape because we have
video James says hey Ben how do you talk
to your kids about the Holocaust I
wonder how best to talk to my kids about
the horrors of slavery without them
viewing themselves as victims PS can you
wish my wife Audrey a happy birthday she
got me a subscription to Daily wires he
gets one Audrey happy birthday
that's that's awesome and thank you for
for rewarding your husband with a
subscription to Daily wire how do I talk
to my kids about the Holocaust they're
too young right now one is five and one
is three I think they will be old enough
maybe when they hit seven or eight years
old and what I will talk about is that
there is a long history of persecution
against Jews in a variety of countries
culminating in probably the worst
persecute
in the history of mankind the Holocaust
it's deeply disturbing stuff this is why
you should be grateful that you live in
the greatest time in the greatest
civilization in the greatest country and
you should be grateful for the people
around you who fought to end that
Holocaust you should be grateful to
America which fought to stop that
Holocaust you should understand that
there's a potential for grave evil in
every human heart including your own and
we should work to wipe away that evil
you should understand that the power of
the collective is so intense that
sometimes people who even consider
themselves decent go along with evil and
you need to stands up and say no you use
it as a moral teaching tool the same
thing I would assume is true of slavery
I wouldn't teach it as you're a victim
because the Holocaust happened I
wouldn't I would teach it as evil is
possible
evil does sometimes specifically target
Jews just as evil does sometimes
specifically target black folks and the
only way to fight it is to stand up and
shout about it and rally good people
around the cause to fight against it
when appropriate without considering
yourself a victim in a society that has
fought to end slavery and a society that
is fought to stop the Holocaust in a
society that that ended Jim Crow the I
mean we it's great to live in a country
where you can say I hope those things
isn't it Kyle says and some of the
research I've come across I've seen the
comparison between CEO wages compared to
their other fellow employees has grown
to around 400 times the average worker
over the past few decades I'm curious as
to the validity of this information and
if it is true economically is there
something we can do or is this something
the economy will sort out on its own
given it enough time well I don't really
see why the gap between the CEO wages
and fellow employees is of concern the
question is whether people are being
underpaid people have said this about
you know the CEO of McDonald's
McDonald's has tens if not hundreds of
thousands of employees and the CEO makes
a few million dollars a year well the
average McDonald's employees making
whatever it is twelve bucks an hour or
something if you were to fire the CEO
and redistribute a salary everybody to
get maybe a five cent raise 10 cent
raise something like that the question
is not what the CEO makes when you
decide whether to hire a CEO you have to
you have to pay him market wages to get
whoever you think is best at that job
and that's something approved by the
board in order to bring in talent and
being a CEO requires years of education
it requires years of
work in a skill set and if that person's
bad they get all the blame obviously so
I'm very little concerned about this
this is just a general point I do not
care very much about income inequality I
care a lot about what happens to people
at the bottom end of the scale and
whether in fact there are systemic
obstructions being put in their way to
grow their income if not then I'm not
concerned that the CEO makes a lot of
money he's not seen he's not stealing
that money from people who are who are
working the counter at McDonald's or
something Chrissy says hey Ben
I recently stumbled across a
one-year-old video of you being
interviewed by Patrick Betts ovide in
the interview stated if Biden runs in
2020 he'll win in 2020 do you still feel
this way if not what has changed in mine
I think that if iDEN wins the nomination
in 2020 he's the odds-on favorite one I
mean just by just by statistics he is
he's more popular than President Trump
on a national level you know President
Trump has a good economy going for him
he's it uncut an incumbent president you
know there are some things that Trump
can do to be competitive but I think
that if you had to put money on it it's
it's at best a 50/50 shot the Trump wins
against Joe Biden in a reelect effort
Natalie says hi Ben
with the recent rocket attacks in Israel
over the weekend a Jewish law question
came in to mind our Jewish soldiers who
protect Israel exempt from observing
Shabbat yeah they are given what is
called a head tear they are allowed to
protect their fellow Jews because it is
a situation of what we call Peak Oil
nephesh a life being in danger when a
life is in danger you're allowed to
violate virtually every commandment in
the Torah with the exception of you're
not allowed to kill somebody like an
innocent person if your life is in
danger you're not allowed to commit a
sexual sin if your life is in danger
and you're not allowed to defame the
name of God basically commit idolatry if
your life is in danger
otherwise you're allowed to violate any
of the rules rice says dear Ben I live
in the UK people on the Left often bring
up the example of Saudi Arabia as a
country we sell arms to and have an
economical relationship with despite the
human rights atrocities they engage in
saying this proves our foreign policy is
all about power and oil what are your
thoughts on the relationship that we
have with countries like Saudi Arabia
how would you respond to these
oversimplifications so the question in
foreign policy unfortunately is what is
the alternative so what I prefer that
Saudi Arabia we're a thriving
westernized democracy yeah that would be
awesome also if we don't support Saudi
Arabia in the region then Iran takes
power that is a very bad thing because
Iran is much more dangerous than Saudi
Arabia in terms of its regional
aspirations as well
as its global terror reach we always
have to consider the alternative when it
comes to foreign policy because again
foreign policy doesn't happen in a
vacuum
winces hey been in history class we were
learning about the Social Security Act
and FDR's policies as governor and
president I was wondering what your
critiques of his policies are and how we
can reduce the welfare state today
well his his socialist his social
policies weren't socialist policies his
policies were very bad for the economy
study from UCLA that suggests they
lengthened the Great Depression by up to
eight years as far as his Social
Security Act that has effectively taken
over 33 percent of the federal budget
and will be bankrupt by 2030 it is my
view that as opposed to seizing money
from people and putting it in a
government account that is then used for
other purposes in what is effectively a
pyramid scheme if you actually wanted to
have the government involved in
retirement which I don't think that it
should be but if you were going to what
you would do is set up personalized
savings account put the money in the
personalized savings account for the
person and then that would be it then at
least they're saving the money but
that's not what Social Security does
there is no lockbox you put the money in
Social Security that Social Security
money then gets sent to somebody else
Theresa says as 100% Ashkenazi Jew do
you speak Yiddish I do not I have a very
low command of Yiddish not no more than
I think the average American Jew at
least let's see um drew says hey Ben I'm
a big proponent of a flat tax rate what
are the objections to it why should a
person living off the system have a vote
equal to someone who pays over 30
percent of their income I also am a big
proponents of a flat tax right usually
people say well dollars matter more as
you go lower down on the scale so
therefore people lower down on the scale
should keep a heavier chunk of their
income but that's what percentages are
meaning that if I pay 30 percent of my
income no matter what my income that's
gonna be a heavy chunk of my increment
it's a lot more absolute money when you
are wealthy than when you are poor in
fact the United States has one of the
more progressive income tax rates in the
Western world rich people pay way more
than poor people and if we actually had
a quote-unquote socialist system it's
the poor who would pay for it the middle
class and the poor which is why the
lowest tax the the highest tax brackets
in many Scandinavian country starts at
around $60,000 Jake says hey Ben love
the show since it is impossible the
Trump wins
California would you consider voting for
Howard Schultz as an independent
candidate instead if he has a
competitive chance
obviously you don't agree with him on a
lot of issues but in terms of fiscal
responsibility and identity politics
he's far more reasonable and moderate
than the rest of the Democrats well if
the idea is that that would throw the
electoral votes away from the Democrats
and toward Howard Schultz and prevents a
Democrat from reaching 270 then yeah
that's just strategic voting so I think
strategic voting is sometimes
justifiable Brennan says do you think
the government should mandate the
parents vaccinate their children as a
conservative I'm very skeptical of
government mandates and what should be
personal choices but not vaccinating
your children can put others at risk
what are your thoughts yes I'm in favor
of the government mandating vaccinations
I know this is unpopular with a certain
segment of my audience I understand that
that is your prerogative
I disagree when it comes to vaccinations
vaccinations do create externalities
lack of vaccination of your child does
not just impact your child
it makes your child a potential carrier
for people who cannot get vaccinations
including kids who have cancer pregnant
mothers and babies under 1 year of age
it's why we've had a returns when
measles outbreak after that disease had
effectively been wiped out of the United
States decades ago okay final question
here should the United States recognize
the Republic of China aka Taiwan is the
rightful government of mainland China
very difficult to recognize Taiwan as
the rightful government of mainland
China when they don't have any control
over mainland China without that
amounting to an effective declaration of
war against China so on a real politic
level I can't see that happening alright
let's do some stuff I like and then some
stuff that I hate so things that I like
so I have to acknowledge that it is
amusing to watch as as Democrats make
claims about the economy that are just
outright false so Senator Richard
Blumenthal who says a lot of very weird
things was on CNBC can you start talking
about Facebook and he makes the case
that breaking up companies like Facebook
would increase jobs and prosperity I
think that Facebook needs to be broken
up the acquisitions of Instagram and
whatsapp need to be on
and there needs to be Department of
Justice scrutiny about appropriate
antitrust remedy so we're not talking
about attacking prosperity or jobs in
fact increased jobs and greater
prosperity in more competition and
really Facebook here is the only company
that we're talking about so yeah when he
talks about you know breaking up
breaking up companies creates jobs and
prosperity so I guess the idea is that
if you have lots of competition in a
sector that creates jobs and prosperity
isn't that the underlying logic there oh
wait that's what we say about everything
in the free market they only say it when
they want to break up a company that is
successful and not jacking customers
alrighty so we will be back here next
Monday I hope that you have a wonderful
joyous and Qom weekend we'll be back
here next week to rehash everything I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
this is the Ben Shapiro show executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stephens edited by Adam sy
events audio is mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19